ERIC LEICHTENSCHLAG:
Hello, everybody.
My name is Eric Leichtenschlag,
from the AdMob
SDK developer relations team
here at Google, and I'm here
today to talk to you about
AdMob Mediation, and more
specifically, custom events and
their use cases and how
you can use them.
So first off, you guys
might be wondering,
what are custom events?
A custom event is a mechanism
used to execute some custom
code in your app that can serve
a view into the ad space
instead of just showing an ad
from a normal ad network.
This could be an ad from a
network that's not supported
by Mediation or any other custom
view that you put in.
So why would you use it?
If you want to incorporate an
ad network that doesn't have
an AdMob Mediation adapter, then
you could write your own
custom event to serve that
network, and you can also show
some custom view instead
of an ad.
So let's walk through how you
can set up this custom event
and write your own code to
serve this custom view.
So the first thing you want to
do is, in your AdMob settings
in your Mediation placement,
you'll want to
add a custom event.
And the custom event has
three properties--
a label, a class name,
and a parameter.
The label is just a name for
your custom event, so in this
example, we called it
AdMobCustomEvent.
The class name is your fully
qualified class path to the
custom class you're
going to write.
In this case it could be
your.package.CustomAd.
And the parameter is just some
parameter that you will need
in your app to make the request
or to get this ad or
this custom view that
you want to show.
We'll walk through some examples
later of how you
would use this.
And then in your app you would
create this class-- that
your.package.CustomAd class--
and that class would implement
the custom
event banner interface.
This interface has
two methods--
request banner ad and
destroy method.
The main one is request banner
ad, and in this method, you
will take in a banner listener,
an activity, your
label and serverParameter
defined on the server, the
AdSize for the request, some
AdRequest parameters, and this
extra object that you can pass
to your custom event from
within your app.
The main things to note here
are the custom event banner
listener, you will use this to
send back notifications from
the custom event to the
Mediation layer to let you
know to tell Mediation that
you've got an ad or you
didn't get an ad.
So in addition to that request
banner ad method, you will
also implement
CustomEventBannerListener, and
you'll take that banner
listener, and you'll send
these messages back, depending
on how your
custom event operates.
If you receive an ad or you
want to show a custom view
into your ad space, you'll call
back with onReceivedAd
and pass the view that
you want to show.
Again, this could be an ad from
another network or custom
view of your own.
And if you don't want to return
an ad, you just call
onFailedToReceiveAd, and AdMob
Mediation will just go to the
next network and try to fetch an
ad from the next network in
your Mediation placement.
You can also invoke onClick
when your ad is clicked.
This'll track clicks in the
AdMob Mediation reporting.
You also might want to call
onPresentScreen or
onDismissScreen if your ad or
custom view launches another
screen and the app is no
longer in control.
So that's it from planning
custom events.
Now we're going to walk through
some sample custom
events that you can implement.
So the first example is
Percentage House Ads.
This example will allow you to
request AdMob House Ads a
percentage of the time.
This is a little bit different
than the AdMob House Ads
network that you can implement
with Mediation.
A couple key differences are
when putting custom ads into
your Mediation placement in the
back end, if you define
your configuration with ECPM,
you might have house ads at
the very back of the flow, and
if you have other networks
that are filling every
request, you won't
show any house ads.
And if you put house ads as a
percentage and do percentage
allocation, then you might get
house ads a percentage of the
time, but then you cannot
configure other
networks via ECPM.
Maybe you have one network that
pays more per click, and
you want to serve them every
time that you're not doing
your house ads, but because
you're doing percentage
placement, you don't really
have that much control.
In addition, AdMob caches the
configuration from the server
for 300 seconds.
So if you get house ads first
from your percentage order,
then you're going to serve house
ads for 300 seconds.
And depending on what your
refresh is, you make it five
or six house ads in a row, and
you might not want that.
So this percentage house ads
custom event gives you a lot
of flexibility.
You can put it first in your
Mediation stack with ECPM, and
the app can control how often it
would show that house ad or
decide to fail, and I'll show
you how that happens.
So the label for this custom
event example is just
Percentage House Ads.
The class I'm going to implement
is com.google.examp
le.ads.customeve
nts.impl.PercentageHouseAds.
And I'm passing in two
parameters here.
Since the parameter is going to
be a string, I'm actually
passing in some JSON, and I'm
going to have the app kind of
decode that JSON and
get these values.
It's going to be the publisher
ID, which is trafficked to
house ads, and you can also set
this up in the AdMob UI,
and as well as a percentage
for how often you want to
serve this house ad.
And below this, we have the
sample ECPM values for
trafficking these ads.
So in this example I have, I'm
going to have house ads valued
higher than the AdMob network.
So what's going to happen is,
I'm going to try House Ads
first, and if that fails,
I'm going to go
to the AdMob network.
So now let's walk through how
you might implement this.
So our custom class is going
to implement the request
BannerAd method, and we're
going to store the
bannerListener for
callbacks later.
And the first thing we're
going to do is
extract these values.
I said we passed in JSON to that
server parameter, and so
we're going to create a new JSON
object here and try to
get the string publisher
ID and the
percentage from this JSON.
If we entered bad JSON, or for
whatever reason we can't parse
it, it will just log a message
and quit, so this fails
gracefully.
If this happens, then we just
won't ever serve a house ad,
and we'll just go on to
the AdMob network.
So at this point, we'll have
our publisher ID as well as
our percentage, and we'll
construct a random number.
And if this random number is
higher than the percentage, we
won't return the house ad, and
if it's less, we will return
the house ad.
So let's pick a random number
and say it's 53.
Since 53 is greater than 50,
we're just not going to show
the house ad.
But if it's less than 50, then
we will show the house ad.
So similarly, if you wanted to
do house ads 5% of the time,
then if the random number was
greater than five, you just
wouldn't show the house
ad, but if it was less
than five, we would.
And creating the house ad is
very simple-- we just creating
a new AdView, pass it the
activity and the ad size and
that publisher ID
from the server.
We set the AdListener so we can
listen for when the house
ad comes back, and we can
send that event back
to mediation layer.
And then we'll just load an
ad with the new AdRequest.
And then in the callbacks, when
we get the house ad from
AdMob, we'll set the
bannedListener and call
onReceivedAd and pass
in the ad view.
So this tells AdMob Mediation,
hey, I have this ad view with
my house ad, please show it.
If for some reason the request
to get the house ad fails,
we'll just tell Mediation that
we failed to get that ad, and
it'll move on to the
next network.
And if we click that ad we'll
call the onClick methods so
that it gets logged in mediation
reporting, and we'll
also call onPresentScreen to
let the user know that we
launched a view on top.
These callbacks are important
because you'll, as the user,
get them when implementing
your app.
So this is custom event code is
separate from your normal
AdMob declaration, but when you
declare your AdMob AdView,
you might want to know when the
user clicks on an ad and
presents a new screen, just so
you can maybe pause your game.
So by having your custom
events send this
onPresentScreen message,
Mediation will then tell you
in your main app code that
hey, we're presenting
something on the screen, and
you can listen for that and
pause your game or something
you need to.
So I'm going to run a little
bit of a demo here.
So I have a couple examples on
this app and the first one
here is percentage house ads.
So in this example, here is this
Mediation ID that I have
set up already on the server.
And in this example, I'm
actually overriding what the
server has with this own
percentage, so that I can just
demonstrate it for you.
Say I put in 50% here
and request ad.
We're noticing that the random
number was 47, and it was less
than 50, so we're going to get
this percentage house ad.
But if I try it again, 87 this
time, is going to be greater
than 50, so we're going to skip
the house ad and based on
the configuration I mentioned
before, we go to AdMob for an
ad, and look, we're getting
back an AdMob ad.
So this is a great way for every
refresh to just check,
hey, should I get a custom
events or not?
And if I change this number to
something like five, maybe you
only want to show house
ads 5% of the time,
then there you go.
92 is greater than 5, so
we'll skip house ad.
So this is a great way to show
house ads a certain percentage
of the time.
As you notice, on every single
request, we're making this
check again.
So you're not going to get house
ads five or six times in
a row like you would if you set
up house ads just via the
AdMob house ads network already
available within Mediation.
You could get a different
ad every time.
And you could set this
percentage however you want.
When you do implement this
yourself, you probably will
not have a percentage input.
Again, you'll get the number
for the server.
And this Mediation ID you'll
also have set up, and so
you're app won't need to
have these inputs.
So the next example is
just the demo again.
We request an ad, so sometimes
we'll get percentage house
ads, the next time we'll
get just an AdMob ad.
So the next demon I have
is for birthday ads.
So this is just a simple example
that says, hey, if
it's your birthday, I'll just
show you this birthday image
instead of showing you an ad.
Maybe if your app gets user
information and knows what the
user's birthday is, you might
kind of as a happy birthday
thing say, I'm not going
to show you ads today.
So we're going to just
go through an
example of how that works.
So this label is just Birthday
Image, and our class name is
going to be BirthdayAds.
And in this case, we don't need
a server parameter, just
for how the implementation
works.
So I just passed
in unused here.
The apps not actually going
to use this parameter.
And then for the ad network
set up, again I have the
birthday image event set at a
higher ECPM than the AdMob
network so that we'll
try to serve the
birthday image first.
So let's now walk through
the implementation
for birthday ads.
So one thing you want to do
for this example that's a
little bit different than the
previous example was we're
going to have to tell the custom
event what the user's
birthday is.
So in your main app code, when
you're creating your main ad
request, you're going to want to
pass in an extra value, and
this can be done through the
custom event extras class.
And we're going to pass in
the user's birthday.
So in this case, we're going
to get the birthday from a
user input, and get the year,
month, and day and pass that
birthday into the
network extras.
Something important to note here
is this extra.addExtra
line with the custom
event label.
So when creating custom event
extras, it's just key value
pairs, but the key has
to be the label
of your custom event.
So going back to this
birthday image--
Birthday space Image--
that's going to have to be the
key to this custom event
extras that you add.
And so I have it here defined as
a constant in my class, and
the value is just going
to be the birthday.
And we're going to
set the network
lectures on that request.
So what this'll do is when a
custom then comes in for
Birthday Image, that birthday
will get passed and as the
custom event extra, and
we'll go through
that in the next slide.
So in our requestBannerAd
method, the last parameter, if
you remember from before, is the
object customEventExtra.
And so, in this case, our class
is going to check the
customEventExtra and try to cast
it as the calendar that
we passed in.
If we, for whatever reason,
can't cast as a calendar or
couldn't pass the birthday or
couldn't find it, we're just
going to fail to receive an ad,
and again we're just going
to the next ad network
and request AdMob.
But if we can parse the
birthday, then we're going to
continue on.
And again if there's some
kind of exception,
it will just fail.
So once we have this birthday.
We can then check if it
actually is their
birthday on that day.
So we can just get the current
date with just creating a new
Gregorian calendar, and just
check if the month and the day
are the same.
And if they are, then it's their
birthday, and we'll show
them this custom birthday ad.
So in this case, I have just an
image that's static in the
app, it's in my resources.
And just the example I have
happened to be an animated
gif, so in this example we'll
just create a web view and
load it with this URL from our
resources, birthday.gif, and
we'll just call onRecievedAd
with that webview.
If it's not your birthday,
will just, again, fail to
receive the ad and just move
on to the next network.
So this is what the
demo looks like.
You can enter your birthday
here, and if it is your
birthday then it'll show this
happy birthday image.
And it's not clickable, so the
user can't accidentally click
it and go to a new screen.
And if it's not their birthday,
then we'll move on
the next network and
get an AdMob ad.
So we'll try walking through
this demo now.
So again, this is the Mediation
placement ID I
already set up on the server.
If you want to set up
your own, then you
could change this.
And today happens to be April
29th, so if I request ad, I
pass this into the user, and it
is their birthday, and so
we get a happy birthday image.
And so maybe in your own
implementation you just
wouldn't show an ad at all.
You would say, it's your
birthday, I'm not going to
show you any ads, enjoy
an ad-free day.
Maybe if we say our birthday
is March 29th, which is not
today, then we'll realize that's
not your birthday,
we'll go on to the next network,
and we'll get the
AdMob ad again.
So that's a cool little
example of how to give
somebody a birthday treat and
just not show them ads that
day and show them this birthday
image, and it's just
a nice touch.
The final example I'm going to
show you guys is an in-app
purchase example.
This in-app purchase ad will
launch an in-app billing flow,
and so you can actually
ask the user to
make an in-app purchase.
Maybe do you want a
get rid of ads?
You can upgrade, make an
in-app purchase to get
something ad free, and you can
show this in a certain amount
of the time.
So I'm going to walk you through
how you can do a
custom event to invoke
an in-app purchase.
So in this case, our label is
just In app purchase, our
class name is going to be the
InAppPurchase class, and we're
also not going to need a server
parameter for this, so
I called it unused.
For my network configuration, I
have in-app purchase turned
on higher, and in this case, I
have AdMob turned off, just so
if the in-app purchase doesn't
work, then we just
won't get any ads.
So how does this work?
In your requestBannerAd method,
the first thing you
want to do is try to find out
if the user made a purchase.
In this case, we're using the
test purchase of in-app
billing library, just kind
of as a proof of concept.
This madeTestPurchase method
is checking the shared
preferences.
So in this example, once we
make the in-app purchase,
we're just going to store in the
shared preferences, hey, I
made the in-app purchase, so I
don't need to do this again,
and just don't show ads.
So if we've already made the
purchase, we're just going to
fail to receive the ad, and
we just won't get any ads.
If we haven't, we're going to
start the in-app billing flow.
So this example is largely taken
from the trivial drive
example provided with the Google
in-app billing library,
version three, and it has all
these helper classes, so we're
going to an in-app billing
helper, pass in the activity
and our public key.
The public key can be anything
if you're just doing the
testPurchase, it doesn't have
to be an actual value.
The first thing we're going to
do is set it up, start it up,
and when the setup finishes, if
this setup succeeds, then
we can move on, otherwise we'll
just fail to get the ad.
And after it sets up, we'll want
to query the inventory to
see have we made a
purchase already.
So sometimes you might have
made the purchase, but not
have stored that you actually
made it yet, you might not
have consumed it.
So this checks for the case
where we actually made the
purchase but didn't consume
it yet, while the
madeTestPurchase check at the
top checks if we already
consumed it.
So in querying the inventory, if
the inventory query fails,
again, we'll fail to return an
ad, because we all know if the
user made a test purchase
or not.
Otherwise, we check
if the purchase is
made, but not consumed.
So once we get this inventory
result, we'll check for the
test successful purchase
SKU, and we have that
testPurchaseInventory if the
testPurchase is not null and
we verified that this is
actually a valid purchase.
Again, when you're doing in-app
billing yourself,
you're actually going to want to
verify that the payload is
valid so that nobody can hack
the in-app purchase.
If you've already made this
testPurchase, then we're going
to consume it, and once we
consume it, we'll just fail to
return an ad, because we've
already made the purchase.
Otherwise, we're going
to get the ad.
We're going to create the in-app
purchase ad and call
onReceivedAd.
So I'm going to walk through
how we create it.
So I just want to go back to the
point that custom events
only take in a view, it
doesn't necessarily
have to be an ad.
So in this case, our ad is
just going to be a view.
So just creating a relative
layout here with a button on
the right side that says
upgrade, and some text that
says, do you want to upgrade?
So here I'm showing how we're
going to add the purchase
button, and when it's clicked,
we're going to start launching
the purchase flow,
iabhelper.launchPurchaseFlow,
with that purchase.
So I didn't show you all the
code here, but we'll have a
sample app kind of demonstrating
this, and we can
walk through it more,
but here's kind of
how the demo works.
Again, we have our Mediation
placement ID up top that I set
up, and you can request an ad,
and if you haven't made the
in-app purchase yet, you'll get
this view at the bottom.
And this is in the same ad
space, and it says, you want
to remove ads?
If so, upgrade.
And if you click the upgrade
button, you'll
make the sample purchase.
Again, if you wanted to actually
do in-app billing,
you're going to want to go to
the Android console and set up
your in-app billing SKUs.
But for this sample, we can
use the sample SKU.
And if you make this payment,
then the next time you request
the ad, you can check, oh, the
purchase was already made, we
don't need to show the ad.
And we just won't show an ad.
So I can't give you a demo on
the simulator here, because it
doesn't have in-app billing
enabled, but I can walk
through some more of
the code here.
So here's the full create
in-app purchase.
We're actually creating a text
view that says do you want to
remove ads?
And that's going to go on the
left side, and the button,
upgrade, is going to go
on the right side with
this onClick listener.
This is done over here.
Here's our queryInventory
finished, we saw this on the
slide as well.
If the result failed, then we're
just going to fail to
return an ad.
Otherwise, we check if we made
this purchase, and if we have,
we're going to consume it.
Something I didn't put in the
slides is once the purchase is
finished and we verified that
the purchase is valid, then
we're just going to save the
testPurchase, which is just
going to put it in shared
preferences, and then we're
going to consume it.
The main reason that we're
consuming it is just for the
sample to be able to clear the
purchase and be able to
purchase it again.
If you want to make it an
infinite thing where you don't
ever consume it, then you can
just not consume, and then
your custom event can just query
the inventory, and if
it's there it knows it doesn't
need to show an ad.
The consuming part was just
for the demo purposes.
Finally, when we've consumed it,
again, we're going to see
the testPurchase and we're just
going to fail to return
an ad, because we just consumed
it, we just made the
purchase, we don't need
to have an ad anymore.
Again, you're going to want to
verify that the payload is
valid when you do it yourself,
but in this case, we're just
always assuming it's true.
And here, just a couple wrappers
for checking if they
made the test purchase.
Again, we're just checking
shared preferences, and saving
the test purchase is also just
done with shared preferences.
We're going to put the Boolean
and commit it.
Also remember that we need to
implement the destroy method
when doing a custom event.
It doesn't really need to do
much, in this case, we're just
setting the activity passed to
us to null so that we don't
have any memory leaks.
So these are all the
demos I have.
Again, custom events are very
powerful, you've seen a couple
examples here of what
they can do.
You can also integrate--
the standard example would be
just to integrate some other
ad network and just return
another ad network's view
within that custom event, maybe
for network that's not
supported for AdMob
directly with an
AdMob Mediation adapter.
Some resources here are the
custom event sample project
will be available on our
Google code project,
google-mobile-dev.
You can download our SDK
from our mobile ads
SDK developer docs.
Google.com/ads/admob is where
you can set up your AdMob
Mediation placements.
To learn more about custom
events, we actually have a
class on it, and you can learn
just more about how customs
events work with the APIs.
We also have our developer docs,
our forum, our Google+
page, and our blog, where you
can just find a lot more
information about AdMob.
And if you have any questions
you can ask us on our
developer forums.
So I hope you guys learned a lot
more about custom events
today and have some cool ideas
about how you can implement
them in your app.
Thanks for watching.